[Music]
if you grew up with this country you
heard the stories of the old robber
barons from the 19th century who crushed
the aspirations of ordinary people
Rockefeller Standard Oil Carnegie US
Steel all the rest of them their
companies were massive and powerful and
at the time they seemed to bend the
entire country to their will but that's
over or is it today Amazon Google and
Facebook also Apple aren't just richer
and more powerful in the old monopolies
or any companies that have ever existed
throughout human history they also have
far more control over our daily lives
what should we do about it
it's got galilee as professor of
marketing at NYU Stern School of
Business used for a great piece for
Esquire calling for the breakup of the
tech Titans biggest company Scott
Galloway joins us tonight Scott thanks
for coming on doctor thanks for having
me so you took a forensic look at these
companies and their effect on the
American economy in American life and
your conclusion was break them up that's
correct you know I think we're at a part
of the economic cycle with the economy
needs to be oxygenated again I don't
think they've done it anything wrong if
you will I just think the economy of
innovation that we've become dependent
upon has gotten to a point where small
companies have difficulty getting out of
the crib and big companies are being
euthanized before they should because
these companies basically choked off
capital and it's effectively can engage
in anti-competitive behavior which any
company does when it's given the assets
yes yellow these companies so I think
it's time we've got a whole lot of laws
against that federal laws so but but
Google for example which has a chokehold
on basically all human information
everything you could know is on Google
and they have an effect of monopoly on
search that seems like too much power
for any organization to have they've got
to misuse it why hasn't Congress done
anything to reduce that power and the
threat to the rest of us well that's the
correct question Google 92% of a market
that by dollar volume is bigger than the
entire advertising market of any nation
and with the exception of the US and
will probably blow by the ad market of
the US just in two years basically
because current antitrust law is based
on the premise that if it's good for the
consumer then it's good for society and
that's what we're wrestling with right
now
as most people have a difficult time
arguing that Google isn't good for the
consumer the problem is we don't know
what we don't know and that is we don't
know what companies would have emerged
if we didn't have a duopoly where
two-thirds of all digital spin go to
Facebook or Google and that's a hundred
and four percent of all growth so if you
work in digital marketing you don't work
for one of the two you joined magazines
and newspapers and that you're in a
business that's in structural decline so
that essentially means that between
Facebook and Google all digital news is
really controlled the purse strings are
controlled by two companies I mean
that's not a threatening concentration
of power I believe it is a threatening
concentration of power I believe that if
Fox or news core had been weaponized my
intelligence arm of the Russian
government they would have incurred huge
fines and advertisers would have
abandoned the network but in the case of
Facebook you have two companies that
control almost all traffic and all
e-commerce and your presence on the web
so if it's not monopoly it's a monopsony
and advertisers have no choice so there
is too much power in the hands of these
companies I don't think they're evil I
don't think they've done anything wrong
I think they do what companies are
supposed to do they're growing their
earnings but I think at some point
referees need to step in through a
yellow flag and I believe these
companies would be better for the
economy broader tax base more jobs may
be fewer billionaires but more
millionaires if there were 11 or 12
companies instead of the four were
discussing here today yeah I don't think
there's a serious conversation about
that on Capitol Hill right now but I
hope you spark one Scott thank you for
that
I appreciate that Tucker